a real growing concern today on the back
of the results we saw just two days ago
because what i want to see is a
first-class education for every child
whoever they are and wherever they come
from what we've seen today is baked in
inequality the gap between those going
to private schools and going to state
schools has got bigger
rather than smaller so for gavin
williamson and the government
on the question of on the issue of
tackling inequality they just got a you
and i think that's completely
unacceptable the gap should be getting
smaller is getting bigger and the
pandemic and their chaotic handling of
it has made it a lot worse well why are
you calling in for him to go do you not
think
another do you think another
conservative minister can do better
johnson gets the policy rather than the
actual minister that's doing this
inequality in education
is unforgivable we should all be aiming
to close the gap
in terms of attainment we had huge
inequality
before we went into this pandemic it's
just got worse and a lot of that is down
to the way that the education secretary
and the government have handled this
with a chaotic system they should have
had a plan b from the start it was
obvious that we might have had to cancel
exams they didn't put a plan in place
had a chaotic system made it very
difficult for teachers but the net
result
is that the gap between those
private schools and state schools has
got bigger and when inequality goes up
in education then it's pretty
astonishing that the education secretary
is still in post and if he won't resign
the prime minister should get rid of him
are you calling for him to resign yes
i've been calling for him to resign for
a very long time when you have a chaotic
approach to education that ends up with
more inequality rather than less
inequality something is going very wrong
these are real lives these are young
people today who got their results to go
on to the next stage of their lives and
their careers
and for the government to say well
there may be more inequality but nobody
could have done better is simply not
good enough you've mentioned about the
attainment gap results come up today uh
61.2 percent of gcse's results from
private schools are awarded seven above
yeah last year it was uh 57.2 the year
before 46.6
um do you think
you know how would you have dealt with
this disparity well um the
gap between those at private school and
those at state school has got bigger so
something is going very wrong i'll tell
you what i would have done i'd have done
exactly what we called for last
september we should have a plan b in
place to say we might have to cancel
exams therefore we need a proper
approach to assessments by teachers
we've been talking to teachers here
today have walked us through just how
little time they had to do the very best
they could in difficult circumstances
back in september
the education sector and the government
pooh-poohed us said we don't need a plan
b we're going to have exams completely
wrong again
net result more in a courtesy for young
people today completely unacceptable
do you think private schools were maybe
too generous in their grade-in i think
overall what was needed was a framework
for consistency so that all schools all
teachers
had a
sound faded foundation for the
assessments that they were going to be
carried out what we what happened was
because the government stuck his head in
the sand
until christmas saying we're going to
have exams we don't need a plan b got to
christmas we had months of chaos as to
what the system would be and then
teachers across the country were asked
to carry out the assessments in a very
short period of time and guess what
we've got chaos guess what we've got
disparity and guess what we've got
inequality heading in the wrong
direction is there any inequality that
this government isn't making worse